that's the first thing the Bible records
a human being ever made on the earth
something to cover where the
outside are you not listening to me
something to
beautify the
outside something to help me feel a
little better about myself listen to me
carefully the one in 12 is ad daed in
the Light of Christ the one in 17 with
with all the precious tones and jewelry
the one in 12 represents God's true
church the one in 17 the corrupt Church
you choose which one you'd like to look
like when you
dress I'm not telling you you choose
because there's no human covering that
can improve your appearance in the sight
of God are you following me and now
today let us learn what the Bible says
about tattoos body markings earrings and
many other articles like that
and if you should consider having a
tattoo or if you should consider
removing the tattoo that you already
have now for questions about tattoos and
anything related to that please join
me next
question a lot of SE Adventists believe
that wearing jewelry example earrings
chains are not a
sin and that they can wear them some
also believe that body t tattoos are not
sin what does God say
hey all
right I knew trouble was coming sooner
or later let's
pray father give us a heart to receive
biblical truth and not social customs in
Jesus name I pray amen go to Genesis
3 we read verse 6 and verse
7 well let's read from 1 to 7 read the
Bible Genesis 3 1-7 we're talking about
ornaments and decorations on the outside
all that stuff we call
jewelry which is such a big
business do you have it now the serpent
was more subtle than any beast of the
field which the Lord God had made and he
said unto the woman ye hath God said he
shall not eat of every tree of the
garden and a woman said unto the serpent
we may eat of the fruit of the Trees of
the garden but of the fruit of the tree
which is in the midst of the garden God
ha said ye shall not eat of it neither
shall he touch it lest you die and the
serpent said unto the woman ye shall not
surely die for God do know that in the
day ye eat thereof then your eyes shall
be opened and ye shall be as Gods
knowing good and evil verse six and when
the woman saw that the tree was good for
food which it was not by the way away
and that it was pleasant to the eyes and
a tree to be desired to make one wise
she took of the fruit thereof and it eat
and gave also unto her husband with her
and he did eat now verse eight and the
eyes of them both were open verse seven
and they knew that they were naked and
they SED fig leaves together and made
themselves aprons what was made in verse
what what was made me
specific aprons of leaves let's go to
verse
21 read for me unto Adam also and to his
wife did the Lord God make coats of
skins and clothe them okay I want to
draw some of your attention what was
made on the first day too slow too slow
too slow light second
day F third day
this an adst Church
past fourth day sun moon and stars fifth
day birds and fish Sixth Day land
animals and human beings question for
you what did Adam and Eve make in that
week of creation nothing nothing all the
making the creating was done by
God go back to Genesis
3:7 we're looking at a principle a
negative principle read verse 7 again
and the eyes of them both were open and
they knew that there were naked sto read
verse 25 of chapter
2 and they were both naked the man and
his wife and were not ashamed are you
with me but that was before sin after
sin they
shamed so what are they trying to deal
with the embarrassment the shame the
guilt that's what they're trying to
handle how do they handle
it they made Aints of leaves now that's
the first thing the Bible records a
human being ever made on the earth
something to cover where the
outside are you not listening to me
something to
beautify the
outside something to help me feel a
little better about
myself are you with
me with this principle in mind now let's
go to Zechariah
3 Zechariah
3 are you there not yet come on come on
find Zechariah find Malachi then work
your way back
Malachi okay you got it
now you sure I said
Zechariah you have Zechariah Chapter 3
what's the first word in
there and he showed me Joshua the high
priest come on standing before the angel
of the Lord and Satan standing at his
right hand to resist him keep reading
and he unto Satan the Lord rebuke thee
Oh Satan even the Lord that hath chosen
Jerusalem rebuke thee is not this a bran
pluck out of the fire verse three now
Joshua was clothed with filthy garments
stop describe the leaves filthy garments
because God had to remove them are you
following me filthy garments now
Joshua's clothed with filthy garments
and stood before the angel keep reading
and he answered and spake unto those
that stood before him saying what take
away the filthy garment from him and to
him he said behold I have caused that
iniquity to pass from theee and I will
clothe thee with change of for amen now
in Joshua we have a symbol of how God
functions he removes that man-made stuff
and replaces it with the symbol of the
righteousness of his son are you with me
now let's go back to Genesis Genesis
3:21 keep the information from Zechariah
3: 1-4 let's go to Genesis 3: 211 unto
Adam also and to his wife did the Lord
God make quats of skins and cloth them
before he put the skins on what did he
have to remove those aprons of leaves
manmade for the purpose of feeling
better reducing a sense of guilt and
shame now to see how worthless the
aprons were let's go to verse 8 of
Genesis 3 and they heard the voice of
the Lord God Walking In The Garden in
the cool of the day and Adam and his
wife hid themselves from the presence of
the Lord God amongst the Trees of the
garden now why are they hiding if
they're already covered because there's
no human covering that can improve your
appearance in the sight of God are you
following me no you're not following
me verse 21 courts of skin the blood of
Christ is what needs to cover us now
having said all of that let us go to
Exodus Exodus no Genesis
35 it's 10 after 7 when is the
sunset it what
Temperance in all things Temperance
Temperance okay we're going to Genesis
35 read from verse one let me pray
father as we continue please Lord teach
us we want to know because salvation is
knowledge teach us dear God In The Name
of Jesus Christ I pray amen now let me
set this up for you in chapter 34 Simeon
and Levi kill all the men in a city
because the prince of that City had
raped their sister Jacob had 13 children
12 boys and one girl you know that girl
is going to be protected when she was
raped Simeon and Levi went to the city
and said to the prince look you the
follow our sister you have to marry her
the prince said yeah I'll marry her but
the boy said you can't marry her because
you're
uncircumcised the prince said we'll get
circumcised so Simon Levi the servants
came and circumcised all the men waited
3 days for them to be properly immobile
are you
following then came with the SWS and
killed all the
men brought the women into captivity and
the children all the possessions of the
city and in the field and took it all
away and when this terrible thing
happened Jacob said the surrounded
tribes will kill me because I'm just a
small group now God is going to get them
out of this are you following me he's
getting them out of this crisis that's
what we're about to read verse one
Genesis 35 and God said unto Jacob arise
go up bethl and dwell there and make
there an altar unto God that appeared
unto thee when thou fled as from the
face of Esau thy brother remember Jacob
running from Esau okay verse two then
Jacob said unto his household and to all
that were with him put away the strange
gods that are among you and be clean and
change your garments this is a spiritual
change you've offended God changes have
to be made put away of strange Gods be
clean change your garments now verse
three what does that
say and let us arise and go up to bethl
and I will make there an altar unto God
that what answered me in the day of my
distress and which was with me in the
way which I went now Jacob said verse
two put away the strange Gods be clean
change your garment verse four read with
me now and they gave unto Jacob all the
strange Gods which were in their hands
and all the earrings which were in their
ears and Jacob hid them under the orc
which was by SH
now all the
jewelry Jacob
took and buried
it go to Matthew 25
Matthew 25 we'll read from verse
14 are you with me you have Matthew 25
verse
14 okay you say yes but you're still
turning Pages all right okay okay are we
there now can I rely on that yes okay
read with me for the kingdom of is as a
man traveling into a far country who
called his own servants and delivered
unto them his Goods next verse and unto
one he gave five talents to another two
and to another one to every man
according to his several abilities and
straightway took his journey now next
verse 16 I think it is now he that had
received the five talents went and
traded with the same and made them other
five talents likewise he that had
received two he also gained other two
read Verse
18 went and digged in the earth and hid
his Lord's money what did Jacob do with
the
jewelry the Earth what does this man do
with the
Tallow signifying
what how did the fellow with five get
10 what did he
do yes he traded he used it are you with
me are you following he used it got went
from 5 to 10 what about the fellow who
went from 2 to 4 he used it he put it to
use the fellow with one what did he do
he bed it meaning what he didn't use
it what did Jacob do with that
jewelry he bettered it it was not to be
used go to Exodus
33 Exodus 33 we have another crisis the
Israelites were full of crisis we have
another crisis these people have just
worshiped the golden calf and God was
this close to wiping them out Moses sent
the Levites with their swords 3,000 were
killed in that day now God wants them to
do something to show repentance or
change of mind and heart verse
one uh Exodus 33 let me know when you're
there read with me and the Lord said
unto Moses depart and go up hence thou
and the people with thou H has brought
up out of the lands of Egypt unto the
land which I swear unto Abraham to Isaac
and to Jacob saying unto thy seed will I
give it keep reading and I will send my
angel before thee and I will drive out
the Canaanite the Amorite and the
hittite and the perizzite the hivite and
the jebusite now verse three unto a land
flowing with milk and honey keep reading
for I will not go up in the midst of
thee for ye are a thou a stiff neaked
people lest I consume you in the way God
to say I am so mad I don't want to
travel with you in your condition
because I'll just destroy
you is God love can God get mad is his
Madness just yes verse four and when the
people heard these evil Tidings come on
they mourned and no man did put on him
it they they refuse to put all jewy
there verse five read it for the Lord
had said unto Moses say unto the
children of Israel ye are a stiff necked
people I will come up in the midst of
thee in a moment and consume thee
therefore now put off thy ornaments from
the that I may know what to do unto thee
verse six and the children of Israel
stripped themselves of the ornaments by
the mount now let me tell you the Hebrew
rendering strip them by the mount means
from the mount H meaning from that point
on they left them
off from Mount Horeb they left them off
subsequent travels we have two spiritual
crisis and God says you need to straight
yourself out on each occasion get rid of
all that
stuff now go to Ezekiel 28
let's read from verse 13 this is a
description of Lucifer before he fell
are you with
me I'm not convinced you are but
okay Ezekiel 28 reading from verse 13
are you there you somewh you still
looking for
Ezekiel all right I give you 10 seconds
to find Ezekiel it's
7:18 you have Ezekiel 28813 read with
me thou Hast been in Eden The Garden of
God every precious stone was thy
covering come on the sardus the topaz
the diamond what else the barrel Onyx
The Jasper what else the sapphire the
emerald the carbuncle and gold keep
reading the workmanship of thy tabrets
and of thy pipes was prepared in thee in
the day that thou was created who is
that Lucifer he was covered with
precious stones
let's find out what his problem was go
to verse 17 and read it for
me come on thine heart was lifted up in
thee why because of thy Beauty come on
thou Hast corrupted thy wisdom by reason
of thy brightness stop when Lucifer
realized how pretty he
was thine heart was lifted up in thee
because of thy Beauty you know you went
to high school the most stuck up person
was the girl who thought she was the
prettiest his outward appearance led to
his I must say that's only reason but it
contributed
now when God made Lucifer he was covered
with all that
stuff when God made
Adam was they sin in the world in the
universe when God made Adam was they sin
in the universe yes who would sin for
Lucifer are you with me so did God know
know the catastrophe he had with this
pretty
angel how did you make Adam give me one
word starts with N naked what did he
have on him
nothing what did Eve have on her
nothing now does God want us to breathe
what did he give us we two holes are you
with me ah you're not listening does he
want us to listen what did he give us to
a with holes
if he want us to wear
earrings he could to put another hole
right here and one right
here uh you don't like me
anymore are you listening to me what he
made Adam and Eve with nothing on them a
baby comes out of the womb and two days
later you pound the hole in the air you
pound in air and you drive a screwdriver
through something and you cuffs on with
a saw to high metal
let me tell you some of Jewelry in
ancient times people wore them to
identify with their
Idols some jewelry formed were called
amulets an amulet was devised to protect
you from evil
spirits some jewry had markings on them
that represented the idols and as the
idols were decorated people decorate
themselves so they look like come on
they
Idols go to Leviticus
19 Leviticus
19 I forgot to welcome those listening
online wherever you are God bless
you and may the truth of his word reach
you
unopposed what B did I say the viticus
what chapter 19 read verse 28
microscopically
are you there and keep in mind the key
word that describes or summarizes
Leviticus is
Holiness read verse 28
now ye shall make no cuting in your
flesh for the dead or print marks upon
you I am now don't cut yourself don't
print marks on
you that's what people did to identify
with the dead and their ancestors whom
they worship are you following me
remember the prophets of Baal on M carel
with Elijah when ba wouldn't answer what
do they start to do cut them don't don't
do that now when God says don't cut
yourself what do he mean don't cut
yourself don't tell God where it's a
little
cut uh Pastor they don't like what I'm
saying don't tell God but it's just a
little cut cuz Adam could have said said
it's just a
grape that's all I consumed why are you
putting me out God said don't do
it now to have earrings in your ear do
you have to pierce
it or some you have here is that a cut
why are you hesitating as though why
tamama is that a cut
yes don't make me
mad the verse says don't br any marks on
your
body are your toes a part of your body
come on tell me you don't sound sure huh
why are they
red
Hello that's a mark now someone is
saying this guy's
extreme I'm not
extreme you either for God or you're not
now let me say there some people
convicted at different times different
time I was preaching somewhere and I
made a call to give up all that jewry
people came and put rings and it on the
table I told the head Elder the pastor
sell it and give the money to the doer
Society they took it off and put it
there go to First Timothy Chapter 2 I
know someone watching me wants to kill
me but the pastor is here to protect me
he won't let me get killed you want to
kill me I you know that I feel that heat
coming from you 1 Timothy Chapter 2
let's read for verse
9 I'll miss you when I'm
gone I really
will God bless you all the days of your
life God bless you God bless you I mean
it First Peter 1 Timothy Chapter 2 do
you have that let me pray father as we
continue teach us God we forget quickly
teach us and soften that Stony heart
that does not like what is being said
said in Jesus name I pray amen 1 Timothy
2:9 says what in like manner also that
women Adorn themselves with modest in
modest power with shamefacedness and
sobriety let me tell you something
modesty is almost
extinct but I was a boy you know what a
modest person looks
like modesty today is almost
extinct people in the church no longer
understand what modesty is I was coming
through Johannesburg South Africa and uh
oh and I saw a lady dressed and the
moment I saw her I was impressed with
the modesty of wishes I wanted to go and
tell her but as a preacher you can't
just do these things people stand you
but I said Lord bless that woman you can
tell she respected herself and she was
not advertising for a man are you
following me she was just dress modestly
covered I I looked at her at admired I
say God bless that woman modesty means
very little in the church today are you
with me because our standards are not
biblical or Ellen White they are the
world finish verse 9 of 1 Timothy 2
again what does that
say in like manner also that women Adorn
themselves in modest apparel with
shamefacedness and Sub in other words
you ought to be ashamed if you walk out
of a house looking like
that come on not with
or gold or pearls or costly array now
there's controversy as to what broaded
here means that I have no position on it
but what we do know there are some
hairstyles the Bible condemns are you
with me now some people were chatting
all right whether or not you understand
what broided hair means it does tell us
there are some hairstyles that God does
not approve of they do not reflect
Christian modesty now you can decide if
yours falls under that or not I'm not
here to do that but I'll tell you that
verse condemn certain
hairsty but there's a holy spirit that
convict you if you're genuine with God
go to 1 Peter chapter
3 we read from verse
one 1 Peter 3 reading from verse one
have you found that no some people still
looking all right we'll wait patience is
a virtue we'll wait you have 5
Seconds you have it now read with me
likewise you wives being subjection to
your own husbands if any obey not the
word they also May without the word be
won by the conversation of the wife
while they behold your Chase
conversation coupled with fear let me
explain that what Peter is telling women
who marry to unconverted men don't nag
the man let him see your holy life and
that you still respect him as your
husband let him see that and that will
win him don't insist he comes to church
he's an adult Don't Badger him until he
seeks mental he leave the man alone just
be faithful to God respect him as your
husband and that will do the work all
right now they also May without the word
be won by the convence of the while
while they behold your chaste
conversation coupled with fear read
verse three who's adorning let it not be
that outward adorning of adding the hair
again
or or of putting on overpower meaning
very expensive close verse four but let
it be the hidden man of the heart in
that which is not corruptible so we have
corruptible in verse four then what is
corruptible what is in verse
three read verse three again who's
adorning let it not be that outward
adorning
of uh or wearing of gold or putting off
a parel expensive course gold all the
weaves whatever people do that is
corruptible meaning it passes away verse
four says but let it be the hidden man
of the heart in that which is not
corruptible even the ornament of a Meek
and quiet Spirit which in the sight of
God is of great price what's in number
three is of no value to God what's it
number four is of Great Value to God and
your child of God your first interest is
what is important to God now read verse
5 interesting verse for after this
manner all time the holy women also who
Trust trusted in God Adorn themselves
stop that's how the Holy Women of the
old conducted
themselves
modestly that's what the Bible
says now let me finish on jury with this
go to Matthew not Matthew Revelation
12 I know the subject is not popular I
know that he is quite as a graveyard
okay Revelation
12 do you have Revelation 12 let's read
from verse one read with me and there
appeared a great Wonder in heaven a
woman cloth with the sun and the moon
under her feet and upon her head a crown
of 12 Stars stopped describe how this
woman is adorned how is she
described clothe with the Sun what does
the sun give
light what were Adam and Eve surrounded
by before they in light keep reading the
moon under her feet what does the moon
give light and upon her head a crown of
12 Stars what do the stars give light
when were they made Genesis 1 Sun Mo and
stars one of the reasons was let them be
for sign for season for days and years
and let them be for lights in the
firmament of the earth to give light
upon the Earth she is adorn in the
light go to Revelation
17 let's look at another woman
you have Revelation
17 let's read verse four what does that
say at the woman was arrayed in purple
and scarlet color and decked with gold
precious stone and Pur what do you
understand by
Deb there's a word the rap World gave us
bling are you following
me watch it now care from the rap world
give us bling I mean the woman in
Revelation 17 she is bling bling it used
to be bling bling then they shorten it
to bling that's what describes her she
was
dead hey couldn't walk straight so heavy
with
jewy now listen to me carefully the one
in 12 is adorned in the Light of Christ
the one in 17 with all the precious
tones and jewelry the one in 12
represents God not through church the
one in 17 the corrupt Church you choose
which one you'd like to look like when
you
dress I'm not telling you you choose
having heard what Pastor randis K said I
think with the question that he asked he
posed at the end of the
video you should be able to make a good
decision whether you should have a two
or you should not now with this and more
videos like this please consider
subscribing to the channel and it will
be appreciated did